Welcome back, Comrade.
The case of SCP-2273 - also known as Major
Alexei Belitrov - has sparked your imagination,
and you need to know more.
But even if you’re not familiar with the
Major, his story, all you need to know is
that it’s one of war, tragedy, and alternate
dimensions.
He first appeared in the town of Danner, Wisconsin,
on the 13th of October, 1989, during an unprecedented
seismic event.
When he was first discovered, the Foundation
researchers assumed that he was an extraterrestrial
being, on account of his advanced organic
exoskeleton.
In a surprising move for such an imposing
creature, Belitrov gave himself up to Foundation
Agents without a fight.
Major Belitrov was then impounded in Foundation
containment Site 17, where he was interrogated
thoroughly.
Over a series of interviews, the Foundation
ascertained that Belitrov came from an alternate
timeline where Russia and the US are locked
in a so-called “War To End The World”,
thanks to advanced military technology given
to them by SCP-1000.
Belitrov had narrowly escaped execution at
the hands of American soldiers, and appeared
in our timeline.
Now, he’s a prisoner of the advanced suit
that formerly kept him alive.
But his story isn’t over.
This last remnant of a cold-war-turned-hot
has plenty left to teach us.
Something that you need to understand about
the SCP Foundation before we go any further
is that it doesn’t only exist in every nation
across the globe, it also exists in every
splinter-reality across the multiverse.
And these splinter realities offer a countless
multitude of tales - of different places,
different people, and different times.
Today’s tale concerns Major Belitrov’s
future, in a universe where the secrecy of
the Foundation is broken, and the anomalous
world needs to find a way to fit in with our
own.
The year was 2018.
Like many humanoid anomalies that the Foundation
was holding in this timeline, Belitrov was
released from containment.
He was no longer an SCP, he was now a mere
Person of Interest, free to move around as
he pleased.
But this didn’t mean Belitrov was about
to enjoy a quiet life on easy street - he
was still an inter dimensional refugee from
a broken alternate world.
Thankfully, there was a certain group willing
to help: The Manna Charitable Foundation.
This anomalous charity has been involved in
a number of strange cases investigated by
the Foundation before, and now, they were
going to lend a hand to Major Belitrov.
Thanks to their Anomaly Reintegration Project,
Manna was able to transport Belitrov back
to his home of Volgograd in Russia.
There, he became something of a national celebrity,
making headlines across the country, sitting
down for interviews on every Russian talk
show, and even being offered book deals.
But as a former military man, Belitrov was
eager to return to government life and run
for a government position.
However, this ambition didn’t go far.
Belitrov was rejected by all the government
bodies he applied to: Even Vladimir Putin
wasn’t eccentric enough to want an insectoid
cyborg from another dimension in his cabinet.
Belitrov endured a rough two years in Volgograd.
He was treated more like a sideshow freak
than a human being - people didn’t want
to rent apartments to him, and he was never
able to find permanent employment.
Even entry level jobs rejected him.
Nobody wanted to get food served to them by
what looked to be a seven foot monster, and
he seemed equally ill-suited to helping Russian
women find the right perfume in department
stores.
In April of 2020, Belitrov had finally had
enough.
He contacted the Manna Charitable Foundation
once again and asked to be relocated.
They told him that some religious institutions
in the area, including the Eastern Clockwork
Orthodox Church, were accepting and housing
anomalous refugees.
Not long after this, Belitrov truly fell off
of the SCP Foundation’s radar.
But one former Foundation operative was well
aware of Major Belitrov’s fate.
It’s 2021.
Dr. Friedrich, the Site-17 Anomaly Psychologist
who’d conducted all the initial interviews
with Belitrov all the way back in 1989, started
receiving letters from him.
There was no indication as to his true location,
and they appeared to have been handled by
a Manna Charitable Foundation Mail Carrier
in Russia, but Dr. Friedrich was happy to
hear from an old friend nonetheless.
Due to a career of working near highly radioactive
anomalies like Belitrov, Dr. Friedrich was
suffering from terminal lymphoma.
It seemed almost like an act of divine providence
that Belitrov’s letters would come to him
so close to the end.
The two began a correspondence, and it was
only after Dr. Friedrich’s eventual death
that the letters came to the SCP Foundation’s
attention.
It was from this final correspondence that
the Foundation was able to answer the big
question: Whatever happened to Major Alexei
Belitrov?
In his first letter to Dr. Friedrich, Belitrov
thanked him profusely.
He knew that Dr. Friedrich had been a crucial
part of him gaining freedom from the Foundation,
and credited the therapeutic techniques taught
to him by Dr. Friedrich with keeping him alive,
and sane, to this day.
Belitrov expressed a mix of amazement at this
brave new world and a sense of profound weariness.
As a man eternally locked into a weapon of
war, he felt unsuited to a world in peacetime.
He almost missed the scorched, irradiated
Russia of his home dimension.
But most of all, he missed Site-17.
He missed Dr. Friedrich.
He missed some of his fellow anomalies, like
SCP-507, the Teleporting Man, and SCP-163,
the Space Crab.
He even missed the simplicity of being contained.
He hoped that Dr. Friedrich would write back.
In his second letter, Belitrov began detailing
his experience with the Eastern Clockwork
Orthodox Church.
Despite growing up in a highly atheistic Communist
environment, Belitrov became enamored with
the ways of the Church.
He found them to be highly accepting of him,
in spite of his unfortunate circumstances.
They displayed a freedom in their faith that
Belitrov had never encountered before, and
he was eager to be a part of it.
With the help of Dr. Friedrich, Belitrov was
also sending letters to some of his fellow
freed anomalies.
He signed off by saying that he had even started
praying - something he’d never even considered
before.
The next letter, sent in 2027, struck a much
more somber tone.
It was sent shortly after Belitrov discovered
Dr. Friedrich’s diagnosis.
He wanted to return and see the doctor one
more time, but the Manna Charitable Foundation
wouldn’t allow him to return to Site-17
- believing he had been abused during his
time there.
Belitrov gave Friedrich his prayers and well-wishes,
and asked for a number through which he could
contact his ailing old friend.
By the time the next letter arrived in 2034,
Belitrov had become a fully-fledged member
of the Eastern Clockwork Orthodox Church.
He referred to the other monks at the monastery
as his brothers and sisters.
He seemed to have finally found a true home
there, and the others fondly referred to him
by the nickname “Father Anvil.”
But the true heart of the letter is Belitrov’s
deep concern for Dr. Friedrich’s health.
Notably, in this letter, he often refers to
Dr. Friedrich by his first name, Thomas, as
though to emphasize the urgency of the message.
After the deaths of several of the anomalies
that Belitrov considered friends, he stated
that he couldn’t handle losing anyone else.
His letter ends with a poignant passage:
“You may be unmarried, Doctor Friedrich,
but you are not unloved.
You have to be strong for me.
You have to be strong for yourself.
If you're ever worried that you cannot find
the strength to continue, think of the garden
you'll plant this spring.
I'd like to share gardening photos with you
again.
Not many of my brothers and sisters here appreciate
the simple beauty of a flower bed or the effort
that goes into growing a patch of vegetables.
It's a beauty I'd like to continue to share.
Trust in the power of our Lord, Thomas, and
trust in the power of modern medicine.
God is smiling on you.
Please, be strong.
With Love and Prayers,
Alexei Belitrov”
This letter arrived on the 15th of February,
2034.
Sadly, Dr. Friedrich had already passed away
four days earlier.
He never got to see Alexei’s final letter.
And it truly was his final letter - with nobody
left for him in the world, Major Belitrov
stopped sending any correspondence.
What we know about the final years of Belitrov’s
life all comes from a few scattered journal
entries, translated from Russian after his
passing.
They provide clues as to the kind of life
he lived during the 29 years the Foundation
could not account for his whereabouts and
actions.
The first entry, written on January 7th, 2035,
paints a grim picture of Belitrov feeling
broken and isolated inside the monastery.
He wrote:
“Today is the day that our monastery celebrates
the birth of our Lord.
However, I feel no desire to celebrate.
All of my friends in this world are dead.
My brothers and sisters are partaking in some
celebration outside my dormitory; all of the
required ceremonies are complete, and neither
they nor whatever is happening out there now
will lighten my mood.”
Belitrov also wrote about losing the comfort
he once had in his faith, and his doubts about
whether he would ever be able to recapture
that comfort.
But he had survived greater traumas than this,
and he would continue to press on.
As the months turned to years and the years
turned to decades, Belitrov climbed through
the ranks of the monastery.
Seeing as the Eastern Clockwork Orthodox Church
practically worshipped the concepts of industrialization
and mechanization, the fact that Belitrov
was permanently encased in a biomechanical
exoskeleton probably made him seem even more
pious to his holy brethren.
The final piece of evidence collected by the
Foundation into the life and times of Alexei
Belitrov came just over twenty years later,
in a final address written to comfort his
followers in preparation for his own death.
Belitrov recounted the details of his own
life: Being born into a world of fire, death,
and mushroom clouds.
Then his life being suddenly saved by forces
beyond his control, only to place him into
containment for almost thirty years.
It was only after accepting the teachings
of the Church, and accepting the Clockwork
Goddess, that he felt he was truly free from
his past.
In this final note, Belitrov lays out some
of the teachings of his new religion: The
belief in a great mechanized Goddess who planned
all of reality.
According to Belitrov, everything in her design
fits together perfectly like cogs in a machine,
turning and twisting in unison to create an
ideal world.
He hoped to be forgiven for the many violent
sins he committed in his military life, and
that his contributions to this new world were
valuable.
At the very end of his final address, Belitrov
wrote:
“I do not believe that my time in this world
is much longer.
Brothers and Sisters, when my time of Judgment
comes, do not mourn me.
I would rather you remember these words: the
Goddess is most pleased with those who seek
kind, non-violent resolution to their problems,
because a machine whose gears grind against
each other is a machine that cannot work.
Seek truth, but also compassion.
The Words are only words.
Seek out the Truth within them.
God bless you all.
Father Anvil.”
A month after authoring this statement, records
indicate that Alexei Belitrov was found dead
in his room, having passed away peacefully
in his sleep from natural causes.
He lived a warrior’s life but died a humble
priest’s death.
The true tragedy in the strange life of Major
Alexei Belitrov is how little choice he had
in his circumstances, but thanks to this tale,
we know that he did what he could with the
life he was given.
His remains lay within the graveyard at the
Eastern Clockwork Orthodoxy monastery where
he spent the last years of his life.
With a life as difficult as his own, we can
only imagine he’s glad to finally rest.
Now check out “SCP-2273 - Major Alexei Belitrov”
for a more in-depth retelling of the original
story, and “SCP-5000 Why?
The Full Story Compilation” for more insanity
from another dimension!